(soft chiming music)
- On a small island in
Russia stands a 300-year-old
multi-domed church that was
built entirely without nails.
Kizhi Island is home
to two wooden churches
and an octagonal bell tower that exemplify
18th century Russian architecture.
The largest building
on Kizhi Island is the
Church of the Transfiguration.
One hundred and twenty feet tall and covered
in 22 domes, the church
sparkles like silver when the sun hits it.
It was a tradition in
Russian carpentry to build
using only wooden logs
with interlocking corners
and no nails or steel reinforcement.
The structure was sturdy enough to survive
until the 19th century when
it underwent restoration
to return it to its former glory.
In 1990, the island was listed as a
UNESCO World Heritage site,
and today the island is
a national open-air museum.
It might just be a legend,
but upon completion
of the structure, it was
said Kizhi's main builder
cast his ax into the water and proclaimed
there was not, and will not
be, another one to match it.